today on the mat wall show a new bill
would finally require porn sites to
verify the ages of their users this is a
very basic step that would help protect
children and yet many people object to
it what possible objection could they
have we'll investigate also a pro-life
priest is kicked out of the priesthood
by the Vatican could Pope Francis
possibly be any more of a disgrace Los
Angeles comes up with a disastrously
stupid plan for dealing with its
homelessness problem and a science
journalist structured her entire life
for three years around avoiding covid
and yet got it anyway what lesson did
she learn from this experience all the
wrong ones of course we'll talk about
all that and more today on the Matt
Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Wade has been overturned and this battle
is now finally leaving D.C and going to
the Grassroots no group in America is
better positioned than 40 Days for life
with about a million Volunteers in a
thousand cities 40 Days for life holds
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities they have a larger presence
in blue states with California being
their largest state some former abortion
facility directors say that these vigils
can cause the abortion no-show rate to
go as high as 75 percent which is of
course detrimental to their abortion
business these law-abiding vigils have
closed many abortion businesses in
America and nearly half of those closed
abortion facilities were in Liberal
cities where abortions will remain legal
including closures in San Francisco
Chicago and Seattle 40 Days for life is
effectively changing hearts and Minds in
the Grassroots to end abortion you can
check out their locations podcasts and
free magazine in 40 daysforlife.com and
it's so crucial that you do because uh
the fight for life is not even close to
over
so if you want more information on 40
Days for Life go to 40daysforlife.com
it may surprise you to learn this but
there are at least a few people in
Congress who are interested in doing
their jobs emphasis on a few a very few
indeed one of the few however is Senator
Mike Lee of Utah who just in the last
couple of days has introduced two bills
with the aim of combating the
proliferation of online pornography
especially as it affects kids the daily
y reports on a great Bill whose only
flaw is that it really reaches for the
acronym in its title so says quote the
shielding children's retinas from
egregious exposure on the net act or
screen act would direct the FCC it's a
mandate that all pornographic websites
adopt age verification technology to
keep children from accessing porn online
the interstate obscenity definition act
or Iota act would uh abolish a
nationwide definition of obscenity
reforming the Supreme Court's Miller
test and enabling prosecution of obscene
content transmitted across States or
from foreign countries
the screen act would direct the FCC to
require commercial websites that
regularly create or platform
pornographic content to establish age
verification technology to ensure that
users of those websites are not Miners
and that minors are prevented from
accessing the content of such websites
notably the bill explicitly states that
any proposed FCC regulation must make
clear that simply asking a user to
confirm that he or she is a legal adult
is not a sufficient screening measure
the Iota would establish a federal
definition of obscenity that would apply
to quote a picture image graphic image
file film videotape or other visual
depiction
now this is not the first time that Lee
has addressed this issue again from the
daily wire it says Lee previously
proposed a bill in September to prevent
sexual exploitation on porn sites the
preventing rampant online technological
exploitation and criminal trafficking
protect act that one's not so bad that
actually wasn't a reach at all that was
well done would require age and consent
verification of those depicted and
sexually explicit or intimate materials
online it would also allow victims of
sexual exploitation to have their images
removed and block uh re-uploads
including any alter edited versions
websites that fail to remove the
reported content could face penalties of
up to a ten thousand dollars per day
victims could also file civil actions
against these sites now so those are the
the bills of course The Usual Suspects
are panicking over these proposed
measures articles and Outlets like Vice
and Gizmodo worry that it could spell
Doom for the porn industry as a whole it
could take down the porn industry which
is music to my ears personally I mean if
you've been listening to a show for any
length of time you know that I'm in
favor of banning porn outright
I would like to ban all of it because
pornography is not speech a person
performing sex on film is engaging in
something all right but it ain't speech
porn is prostitution okay uh very
clearly it is it is monetized sex it is
transactional sex it is sex as a product
to be consumed
if old-fashioned prostitutes cannot
claim First Amendment protections then
neither should the prostitutes who
happen to use the internet to [ __ ]
themselves out
but that's a topic for another day okay
that's that's
a different topic because these bills
would not ban pornography they would
rather put some very basic safeguards
and restrictions in place to sort of
safeguards and restrictions that every
other industry in existence has to
contend with
porn has existed in its own special
Universe up until now free of pretty
much all restrictions and regulations
it has been allowed to do whatever it
wants
that doesn't make any sense and has
never made any sense
and now that we live in a culture that
is drowning in porn billions and
billions of hours of porn consumed every
year Children First Exposed on average
at the age of 10 or younger
it is way past time to start thinking
more seriously about this so let's focus
just
on the first bill for right now
um which ought to be the least
controversial of of all like this should
be something that every sane and decent
person can immediately agree to
the screen act would again simply
require that porn sites make a serious
attempt to verify the ages of its users
that's all it does
right now they are not required to do
anything
many sites don't even so much as
required users to click a button
confirming that they're 18 years old you
have to do that if you want to go uh you
know to to Miller lite's website if you
want to go to the to the website of a a
brewery or Distillery
um
you have to verify you have to you have
to verify you have to at least click
something saying that you're that you're
21 you're drinking age
now that doesn't really achieve anything
because obviously anyone can click the
button but even that symbolic gesture
towards trying to protect children isn't
done when it comes to porn
nothing is done nothing
billions of hours are the most depraved
and perverted sexual images imaginable
and many more hours of stuff that is not
even imaginable for most of us is just
one click away for any child on the
internet all the time there are no
barriers there are no safeguards there
is nothing
nothing this is totally indefensible
we are simply handing generations of
children over to the porn industry
knowing about the devastating
psychological effects that documented
proven long-term harm this exposure
causes we know that yet as a society
we are doing absolutely not one thing at
all to stem this tide
and still now even after all this many
people recoil in horror at the at the
you know the suggestion of something as
simple and common sense as age
verification
many of these people would call
themselves conservatives too
so I tweeted about this bill earlier
this morning and some of the responses
just you know are typical and I think a
good representation of how people
respond to stuff like this so reading
just a few of how people responded Matt
Walsh and Mike Lee want government to
come to the rescue with regulations on
businesses
someone else says I absolutely oppose
the government assuming parental
responsibilities
if you don't like porn then don't watch
it why do you always why do you guys
always want to take away freedoms it's
so bizarre
someone else says age verification
technology that sounds pretty
frightening in and of itself why not
just keep kids off the internet
unsupervised
someone else no thanks I don't want to
use any identification to wank parents
should be the ones keeping children from
this content not the government
so this was a general consensus there
were also references to free speech from
these Brave Warriors for Liberty who
believe it is our sacred responsibility
to honorably defend the rights of smut
Peddlers to expose our children to
hardcore pornography
they declare you know I may not agree
with this orgy you film but I will
defend to the death your right to
distribute it openly on the internet
without restrictions so that
nine-year-olds can access it
what an inspiring mantra
now let me let me make a few points here
first of all
age
verification
already exists on the internet
if you want to use a gambling site for
example you will need to verify your age
with a credit card or an ID or maybe
both
nobody complains about that Nobody Cries
Out that their free speech rights are
somehow being infringed because gambling
sites have barriers in place to prevent
10 year olds from gambling nobody has
any issue with it
it's only with porn that suddenly it
becomes as the one tweet said
frightening
age verification exists outside of the
internet too
if you want to buy alcohol you are
required to show ID and the store that
sells it is required by law to ask for
your ID if they don't ask and they're
caught not asking they could face severe
penalties
could take their whole business down
again you rarely hear anybody complain
about that
okay nobody argues that the liquor store
down the street has the First Amendment
right to sell whiskey to 12 year olds
and although kids can get their hands on
alcohol anyway obviously nobody says
that the proliferation of alcohol means
that we might as well just allow the
liquor store to sell the whiskey to the
seventh grader
as we see with any other adult oriented
product
the people Distributing whether in real
life or on the Internet are required to
take Serious steps to attempt to verify
ages
in every other example you can think of
tobacco alcohol gambling guns
the people Distributing this stuff are
required whether on the Internet or in
real life are required to verify ages
the question is whether hardcore porn
sites should be the one exception to
this
should we continue to carve out an
exception wherein every other 18 plus
business has to verify ages but the
site's Distributing pornography to the
masses should not
they get to be special
there's just no coherent argument for
that position
it just doesn't exist
the only argument is the one we heard
from one of the tweets there and it's a
terrible argument but it was honest at
least
the real argument against age education
on for porn sites is that porn users
don't want to be mildly inconvenienced
in their pursuit of masturbation
materials that's the argument
they want to be able to masturbate to
pornography uh as quickly as possible
find as much as they can as quickly as
possible and they don't want any
hindrance any inconvenience at all
and if that means exposing tens of
millions of children to this content
that will uh that will you know have
devastating and traumatic psychological
effects they're fine with that
I gotta tell you I don't find that
argument compelling I I just don't
second point
it's the parents job they cry out
well of course it is parents should be
doing everything they can to protect
their children from this material but
there are bad parents out there lots of
them neglectful parents what do we say
to those kids you're out of luck
sorry kid nothing we could do for you
I mean it yes it's a parent's job to
feed their children also but if a parent
decides not to feed the child do we
simply just leave the child in the care
of the parent and let him starve to
death for fear of becoming a nanny state
no the fact that parents have
responsibilities to protect their
children
doesn't mean that the government has no
responsibility to protect children
is that the argument the government has
no responsibility to children at all
now the government May abuse its power
it does that all the time and yet it
exists for a reason
and protecting its citizens is the
primary reason
do kids not count do they not deserve
protections as well
I mean no matter what you say about the
government you want to be protected you
expect the government to fill its
obligation to protect you
no matter how much of a Libertarian you
claim to be when push comes to shove you
expect there to be basic protections put
in place to protect you by the
government
and you demand it you insist on it
do kids not deserve protections
because remember something
kids
they they cannot consent to being
exposed even if a kid of a 10 year old
goes on Google and types something in
that causes pornography to pop up
and they click on it the 10 year old is
not consenting to being exposed to that
because 10 year olds cannot consent
average age of first exposure of
pornography is 10 years old these kids
cannot consent to being exposed to this
material they cannot consent to being
third-party witnesses to a sexual act
which means that they need to be
protected from it because they cannot
protect themselves
you could say that the parent has the
primary role here but are you really
going to tell me the government has zero
role none at all
and if you are telling me that again why
don't we apply this logic to any other
industry it's a parent's job to make
sure that their kids aren't smoking or
drinking and yet we still have laws in
place forbidding the Alcohol Tobacco
industries from selling their products
to kids
these laws may not be anywhere close to
100 effective but the other option is to
Simply let the industries do whatever
the hell they want and sell directly to
kindergartners if they want and
obviously nobody is in favor of that
unless it's pornography
one final point
not every child who ends up exposed to
porn
has a bad or neglectful parent because
thanks to the porn obsessed losers who
break down in tears of the suggestion of
any restrictions or regulations at all
on the porn industry we now live in a
society where this stuff is absolutely
everywhere it is extremely difficult for
a parent to Shield their kids from it
indefinitely we we are and we are not
doing parents any favors we're not
helping parents at all
so you could say to the parents this is
your job okay but can we help them out a
little bit
you know hey parents this is your job
and we're going to intentionally make it
as impossible as we can for you
this is society's message to parents on
like everything now
we say it's your job and we are going to
do nothing in fact we are going to rig
the system to make it more difficult
every step of the way
what's wrong with telling parents to do
their jobs while also having policies in
place that make those jobs at least
halfway feasible
is it really so frightening so
terrifying
the thought of having a society with
laws that are meant to help and protect
families
does that scare you
well this is orwellian we're actually
valuing families and children this is
this is dystopian
the idea of living in a country where
the laws are more concerned with
protecting families than protecting
[ __ ] and pimps on the internet
that scares you
doesn't scare me
what scares me is the fact that we live
in a country where this even needs to be
a conversation
because the answer is so damned obvious
now let's get to our five headlines
if you're somebody who's always wanted
to read and understand the Bible but
you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible in a year
podcast is currently the most popular
religion podcast in the US millions of
people have listened to it and twice
it's hit the number one spot on Apple
podcast which is really truly amazing in
the Bible in the year father Mike
Schmitz reads the entire Bible in 365
daily episodes
providing helpful commentary reflection
and prayer along the way
what better way to start the new year
looking for New Year's resolution here
it is you can find the Bible in a year
podcast with father Mike Schmitz for
free and your favorite podcast app or on
YouTube plus you can follow along with
special reading plans to help you better
understand the story unlike any other
Bible podcast Bible near follows a
special reading plan that organizes the
books of the Bible in a way that helps
listeners understand the story so get
this reading plan at ascensionpress.com
Walsh if you want to start reading more
importantly understanding the Bible this
year go to ascensionpress.com wolves to
download the reading plan for free
that's ascensionpress.com Welsh to
download the reading plan for free
all right we'll start with this from the
uh from the AP it says the Vatican has
defrocked an anti-abortion U.S priest
Frank Pavone for what it said were
Blasphemous Communications on social
media as well as persistent Disobedience
of his Bishop who repeatedly told him to
stop his partisan activism for Donald
Trump a letter to U.S Bishops or the
Vatican ambassador to the U.S uh
Archbishop Christopher Pierre obtained
Sunday so the decision against Pavone
who heads the anti-abortion group
priests for life has been taken had been
taken November 9th and that there was no
chance for an appeal
the phone has been in conflict with the
bishop of uh Amarillo Texas for over a
decade over his pro-life and partisan
political activities that came to ahead
in 2016 when he put an aborted fetus on
an altar and posted a video of it on two
social media sites the video was
accompanied by a post saying that
Hillary Clinton the Democrat platform
would allow abortion to continue and
that Trump and the Republican platform
wanted to protect unborn children
um now
so they they defrocked the priest so
what they call Laya sizing the priest
and turning him into he's kicking him
out of the priesthood this kind of thing
does not happen I can tell you if you're
not Catholic this sort of thing
does not happen very often this is a
rare step
and in this case it's a rare step being
taken against one of the most prominent
pro-life
activists in the priesthood
not one of the most he's the most
prominent
pro-life priest in the country
and they kicked him out of the
priesthood
now
first of all uh
to the extent that this stems from the
video which this was back six years ago
with a video where he had the aborted
baby on the altar
from what I understand first of all
obviously the baby was given a proper
burial uh and it also was not a
consecrated altar from what I understand
which which which is an important detail
um this was an intentionally shocking
Act
meant to show the brutality and horror
of abortion now people find this sort of
thing unsettling of course they do they
should I do
but when you're fighting when you're
fighting an historic genocidal horror
the sort of thing that most people in
society prefer to turn away from
then you need to shock them awake
sometime you force them to confront it
visually
um and you know there's always this
debate the pro-life communities like to
what extent do we show the victim images
to what extent do we put that front and
center
and there could be a conversation about
the right context for that but what is
absolutely certain
is that you cannot allow the victims to
be entirely erased
what it looks like that this needs to be
seen the visuals need to be seen
and you take any other example in
history of people fighting against a a
genocidal horror
images were always crucially important
because you can describe it all you want
people need to see what it looks like
and also keep in mind these children are
usually dismembered and thrown out
literally as trash into a medical waste
dumpster um that's usually what happens
so father Pavone rescued this child from
that fate it's very difficult to claim
that he what he did was somehow more
disrespecting to the victim than the
faith of that child's body would have
otherwise suffered which again would be
to be thrown out as trash
the point here is the opposite is to
show the victim's Humanity
and besides all that how is this
blasphemous
you know we could have an argument you
could say that it's inappropriate it's
shocking there's all kinds of
descriptions that you could that you
could uh come up with and we could argue
about whether they apply but Blasphemous
let's Blasphemous about that
and however you feel about that
um however you feel about it
the fact is that
if anything his sin here is being too
zealous too militant in the fight for
The Unborn something that I don't really
think is possible to be honest with you
the idea that he would be defrocked for
this kicked out of the priesthood is
just its grotesque especially
considering all of the priests who are
not kicked out
as I said this is a very
uncommon
uh measure that is taken it does not
happen often
I think maybe there was a time when it
was more common but these days things
like defrocking priests withholding
communion excommunicating people
um these sorts of of kind of ultimate
punishments and measures are really
uncommon these days
and yet there are if you're going to
start doing that sort of thing
there are all there's there's a whole
line of people that should be far in
front of of Someone Like Father Frank
Pavone
James Martin
this may be a name you've heard he's a
Jesuit heretic but I repeat myself
openly defies the church's teachings on
a number of central moral issues
especially sexuality
he he's a he's a gay pride flag waving
blasphemy blasphemer touting acceptance
of sexual sin promoting gay marriage and
all the rest of it
openly defying the church's moral
Authority moral teachings in fact he has
also stated explicitly that the Bible is
incorrect in its moral judgments on
homosexuality he acknowledges that those
judgments are in there but says that
it's incorrect
now he tweeted this a couple years ago
apparently quoting someone else but
clearly in in agreement he was quoting
him he said interesting where the Bible
mentions same-sex sexual behavior at all
it clearly condemns it I freely grant
that the issue is precisely whether the
biblical judgment is correct
the Bible sanctions slavery as well and
nowhere attacked it as unjust
oh nothing you know no big deal here
just a priest one of the most prominent
ones in the country saying that the the
moral teachings in the Bible are are not
correct
which of course raises all kinds of
questions that if it's not correct about
this then what else is it incorrect
about
is there any reason to think it's
correct about anything else
you have just
um totally undermined the moral
Authority
of the Bible
and as a priest you have undermined the
moral authority of the church that's
what that's what James Martin is doing
is he getting defrocked is he getting
laya-sized not anywhere close
instead priests like him are taken and
given positions of prominence you know
they're welcomed into the Vatican
they're put in positions of power
by this Pope Pope Francis who is an
absolute disgrace
he is a disgrace and a disaster
all right another church related story
um this is from New York Times
Stonebridge Christian Church in eastern
Nebraska is known locally for hosting a
big annual fireworks event which this
fall included 15 food trucks and
portable fire pits for making s'mores
but it's the Christmas season that is
our Super Bowl so the church's executive
Pastor Mitch Chitwood this year the
church has four locations in the Omaha
area will host four jingle jam family
parties in December and nine services on
Christmas Eve complete with classic
carols Christmas themed coffee drinks
and festive photo booth in the lobby
what they will not have is church on
Sunday December 25th on Christmas Day
Stonebridge will offer a simple
community breakfast but no religious
services at all Chitwood said we still
believe in the Sunday Morning Experience
but we have to meet people where they
are and where they are on Christmas Day
is usually at home in their pajamas this
year church leaders are grappling with
what may seem like an odd dilemma
Christmas Day falls on a Sunday for the
first time since 2016 and that's a
problem Christmas is considered by most
Christians to be the second most
significant religious holiday of the
year behind Easter but most Protestant
churches do not attend most Protestants
do not attend church services on
Christmas Day when it falls on a weekday
if everyone from the pews to the pulpit
would rather stay home what is a
practical house of worship to do this
year some presidents churches are
deciding to skip Sunday Services
completely
and it's a long article giving all these
examples of uh these churches that are
that are closing down for Christmas
not only closing on a Sunday and also
Christmas
so you would think that
Sunday and Christmas coincide all the
more reason to have the the churches
open although any both of those reasons
individually are reason enough
instead it goes the other way it's like
it cancels each other out it's this
weird mathematics where Chris Sunday and
Christmas cancel each other out and so
therefore church is canceled
I gotta say I I don't get this and um as
I've talked about this a little bit and
I think we talked about the show maybe
last year and I didn't realize how
widespread this is
it doesn't make any sense to me
Christmas is one of the holiest
Christian holidays it's it's it's not
our most sacred holiday as the article
surprisingly uh correctly points out but
it is very important
I mean it's up there celebrating the
birth of Christ you know and and and we
have to keep Christ in Christmas that's
what every Christian says
and yet many of these Christians go to
churches that close down on Christmas
because that's a good way to keep Christ
in Christmas close your church
of course the justification that we
often hear for this and here for this
and we also hear this in the article is
that the pastors themselves have
families and and they want to be with
their families on Christmas
all right that yes
and um
that may be the case except that if
you're a pastor
you you are a pastor you got into this
line of work this is like I don't know
this is like uh deciding that you want
to go into business selling fireworks
but then closing up shop around the
Fourth of July
like you know it's it's it's if it's
really important to you that that uh
that you don't have to work on Fourth of
July weekend
then maybe you should be doing literally
anything else in your life besides
running a firework stand
this is what you're there for this is
like this is it as it says there in the
article this is your Super Bowl
so if you want to run a church and yet
you want to be home on the Christian
holidays well
maybe you shouldn't be running a church
and I'm like I'm not saying you have to
go to church on Christmas day
um we usually go to church on Christmas
Eve and that's that's fine that counts
you know that's been our tradition in my
family
um in fact ever since I was a kid it's
been my favorite church service of the
year my favorite Master of the year has
always been Christmas Eve
uh we really enjoy going on Christmas
Eve
that that's not the issue the issue is
with literally shutting your church down
entirely on Christmas not even giving
the faithful the option of going to
church to celebrate Christ's birthday on
the actual day
and you have to think about the message
that this sends
people wonder why the churches are dying
well I mean
if the church is sending the message
that their services aren't needed on
Christmas
then
why are they needed any other time
if it's not important to go to church uh
if it's not important enough to go to
church on one of the most significant
Christian holidays it's so unimportant
you could shut the church down then
I think a lot of people in the public
say well what what do I need you for at
all was it why is it ever important to
go to church
and what is the message I mean
the pastor is skipping one of the
holiest holidays because he wants to
stay in his pajamas on Christmas morning
he wants to eat he wants to wear his
Christmas PJs and eat a late breakfast
and so Church isn't all that important
in that case on that particular day
why would anyone take the church
seriously that's the question
all right
this is uh extremely revealing I know
you don't like to hurt hear the word
revealing used in the same sentence as
Rachel Levine but here it is
um Rachel Levine at I don't know what
event this is doesn't matter
is that some kind of event
talking about his own experiences with
uh transitioning and I want you to
listen to what he says here it is
you know my transition was very
different because for many reasons
professional and mostly personal reasons
I transitioned over 10 years right most
people don't take that long to
transition first of all young people are
not willing to do that anymore and you
know I mean I don't know if I was 50 if
I was 15 now I don't know if I would
have taken so long but you know but
again when I was 15 what were you going
to say and who would you tell and how
would you possibly Express that but um
so the language started about you know
so that was now 20 years ago when I
started when I kind of started this
journey and it was starting to become
more in culture in the internet and
support groups Etc so
um so I took a long time I don't regret
any of that at that but I have no
regrets because when I transitioned with
I was young and I wouldn't have my
children
I can't imagine a life without my
children
and so every experience led me to here
and
um and so how could I regret that
uh
amazing not really amazing this is the
kind of this is the kind of uh
incoherence that we expect from these
kinds of people
I mean the first first of all the fact
that he has kids
uh it just
you know it makes me feel so terrible
for these kids so I imagine are probably
older now in adults but uh no matter
what age they are
you know this just goes to show
how intensely self selfish
all of this is the trans agenda
along with all the other problems with
it that we talk about all the time
it's incredibly selfish
think about what you're doing to your
kids when you hear about these grown
adult men who discover that they're
really women they want to live as women
so you have no concern at all for what
this is doing to your kids
no concern doesn't matter to you
and then all we ever hear is oh I feel
so I feel so much better I feel so much
better
I don't care how you feel
that's not the point what about your
kids
how do they feel
with their dad now dressing up
pretending to be a woman
how does it make your kids feel
and according to you you've so if you
actually are now a woman you have just
taken
by your own logic you have just taken
the children's father away they no
longer have a father
they thought they did
but it turns out according to you they
don't
like that if you if you have any
capacity for caring about anyone else
besides yourself
that should be reason enough to suppress
whatever internal things going on that
makes you have these feelings
suppress them go to a counselor a real
counselor a good one not many of those
but find one
the fact that you have kids should be
reason enough
that you're not going to take you're not
going to take a child's father away from
it
but
also uh he says that though I can't
imagine life without my kids you know
and and if I transitioned earlier I
wouldn't have kids
and yet he still thinks it's perfectly
fine
to transition kids
yeah that's right because if you
transition uh early as a child what
comes with that is sterility
we are sterilizing kids
removing their ability to have children
in the future
and so he can look back and say that
well I'm I'm really glad that it took as
long as it did to transition and that I
did it in adulthood so that I still had
kids meanwhile in the next breath he is
advocating for doing this as young as
possible to kids so that they never have
that option
I mean what do we imagine do we imagine
that he doesn't he doesn't notice the in
the uh inconsistency here the
contradiction of course he does
he just doesn't care
I mean this guy doesn't give a damn
about his own kids you think he's gonna
care about anybody else's kids
all of this everything take Rachel
Levine everything he says his whole life
everything
is just about affirming himself he's
just constantly trying to affirm and
rationalize and justify
himself and his own preoccupations and
his own self in his own uh
self-perceptions that's what all of this
is about
and he will enlist generations of
children to follow down this same path
because it makes him feel better about
himself it's the only thing he cares
about
all right the mayor of Los Angeles Karen
bass is uh given her plan for dealing
with homelessness and uh here it is
are you still going to allow LAPD and
sanitation officers to do these sweeps
of encampments
these are not sweeps at all this is
getting people to move on their own but
then after the person leaves sanitation
is absolutely going to have to be there
no question about it but this is not
coercing people this is not ticketing
people or incarcerating people this is
moving people from tents to hotels or
motels
oh yeah okay so you just take the
homeless people
take them out of the tent put them in a
hotel or motel because that's how you
solve the homelessness problem
which is like it's like solving the
drunk driving Problem by you know
putting more padding on the inside of
the car and telling drunk people to wear
a helmet if they're gonna drive
you're not you're not you're just
facilitating more drunk driving that way
you are facilitating more of the
behaviors that lead to the drunk driving
deaths because
um that's that's the thing if we have a
problem with drunk driving deaths and
injuries the issue is with the behavior
obviously that leads to those deaths and
same with homelessness
uh
you know I have to keep making this
point homeless people
are not homeless simply because they
lack homes
they're homeless because they'd rather
spend their money on drugs
than on anything else
okay they're homeless because they're
addicts and or because they're mentally
ill and obviously those things are
certainly not mutually exclusive
an able-bodied mentally stable sober
person is not going to be out sleeping
on a park bench it's it's
not going to happen most of the time in
in in in the very rare circumstance when
it might happen it will only be for a
very short amount of time
so we take these people that are years
and years living out on the street
um it's just
it takes the most minimal competence
to be able to make enough money to
afford some kind of living Arrangement
may not be a mansion may not be a nice
living Arrangement but if you're sober
and mentally competent there is rarely
going to be a reason why you wouldn't be
making enough money to sleep somewhere
that isn't a Subway great
now this is not about being cruel to the
homeless is quite the opposite
it's about acknowledging what drives the
problem
which which is more than what most
people are willing to do so we talk
about the homeless problem and uh and
the conversation never goes anywhere
because we're not actually acknowledging
what the problem is
we're acting as though people just end
up homeless you know like anyone could
end up homeless you take someone who's
sleeping in a box on the side of the
road or whatever live it living under a
bridge
we want to pretend it's like well any
one of us could be just in that spot
tomorrow
that's just that's simply not the case
and because we can't acknowledge what
lies at the root of the problem that's
why we end up doing these monumentally
stupid things like sending mentally ill
drug addicts into hotels
where as we've seen in the past they
probably proceed to trash every room
that you put them in they drive away all
the business
who knows maybe they maybe they send the
hotel owner into homelessness himself
because uh because it's destroys their
business
is what happens when you refuse to
acknowledge the actual source of the
problem
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
Black Rifle coffee company is helping
you to knock out your holiday shopping
with a ton of awesome new products this
year designed for folks who love country
and coffee you can shop Brewing gear
thermoses mugs apparel for 10 off of
promo code Walls Black Rifle coffee
source is the most exotic roast from
around the globe all coffee is roasted
here in the US by veteran-led teams of
coffee experts every purchase you make
with Black Rifle helps support veteran
and first responder causes daily wire
plus kitchens are stocked with Black
Rifle coffee and yours can be too so go
to Black riflecoffee.com use promo code
Walsh for 10 off on coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's
blackriflecoffee.com with promo code
walls for 10 off black raffle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
all right hopefully you've all uh
finished your Christmas shopping by the
way
I'm I'm almost done the uh shopping uh
you know my own Christmas shopping
mainly because I only have one person to
buy for which is my wife and this is why
I say it every year just like a PSA
um that I I cannot recommend marriage
enough during the holidays I recommend
it
during every other time of year too but
especially during the holidays and
especially if you're a man
um because
if you're a man once you're married
almost all the gift shopping is farmed
out to the wife she buys everything I
mean I buy it because like I it's I'm
making the money that buys it but she's
the one who goes out and actually makes
the purchases and picks the gifts and
keeps track of everything and she has
the the flow chart the spreadsheet going
and she knows who gets what and
everything I couldn't even begin to do
that and so uh
she takes care of it and then we sit
there on Christmas morning and it's the
classic dad thing where people are
opening gifts and a kid runs up thank
you Daddy for what what did I oh yeah
for that I remember getting you that
it's fantastic
and here's what gets me though my wife
is a she's a she's a pro at gift
shopping she gets people the best gifts
she finds great deals she's the kind of
person who she'll buy someone a
Christmas gift in July if she's out she
sees something and says oh this would be
great for this person on Christmas and
she'll buy them a gift in July
um she does that and yet somehow she
complains that I'm hard to shop for and
this is this is a complaint that you
hear from wives all the time that their
husbands are hard to shop for but I I I
don't understand that it's the exact
opposite we are we are the easiest are
you kidding me it's I'm a simple man
whiskey flannel cigars fishing rods
socks
or a gift card I would take that too
that's it choose from those options
that's all you need to do every
Christmas like clockwork just give me
the same thing every single year I'm
fine with it
so I'm the easiest one to shop for I
think what happens with women
is they make it harder on themselves
because they think that they have to put
they have to be creative and they have
to put thought into the gifts so they're
too thoughtful
it's the worst mistake you can make when
you're buying a gift when you buy a gift
for a man worst thing you can do is be
thoughtful
just don't put any thought into it ask
him what like you know the things that
he likes ask him what he wants and just
get that and that's it
no man has ever opened a gift and it was
something that he wanted and then said
well it was like disappointed because it
seemed like well he just got me exactly
what I said I wanted I was hoping you
would surprise me no man has ever
thought that I guarantee you especially
if he's a dad because this is something
that happens when you become a dad even
more so where it's just there's there
are the dad gifts and it's the dad gets
the same gifts every single year I
remember when I was a kid my dad would
get the same gifts year after year after
year and as a kid I would look at that
and I would think what this isn't Fun
for him at all how could this be and so
some years we would try to surprise them
with something creative and he would try
to hide it but we could always tell he
was disappointed when he opened it
because he just wants his gifts
so you don't even need to wrap it just
take the dad gifts put them in a plastic
grocery bag
right on with Sharpie dad gifts and just
throw them out you know Christmas
morning and I'll sift through them later
and we can that's
perfect Christmas okay that's all you
need to do all right
Jack says disappointed to hear that you
only defend free speech for those you
agree with I thought you had better
principles than that
um no that's uh that's not what I said
last week when the left was claiming
that their free speech was infringed
upon because some journalists were
temporarily suspended on Twitter for
doxing people first of all it was not a
free speech violation because they
violated uh the terms of service they
violated the rules and the rules were
applied to them consistently for a
change
so not a violation of free speech at all
but then yeah I I do also say that uh
even if it had been a violation of their
free speech
um I most likely would not have defended
them and I I'm not one of these people
who's going to claim as referenced
earlier you know I I hate what you say
but I'll fight to the death for your
right to say it
when it comes to left-wing journalists
no I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't
fight to the death for their right to
say whatever they're saying I wouldn't I
I I would my life's too valuable to give
it up for these
for these scumbags No in fact it's quite
the opposite I it's good for them to get
a dose of their own medicine you know we
we can
talk about we can describe the medicine
talk about how horrible it is but
sometimes people need to learn by doing
they need to learn by experiencing it
and I am a fan also of holding people to
their own standard that's all I think
and I think that's perfectly consistent
you should be held to your own standard
it's the only way if we want these
standards to be abolished the only way
to do that
uh if we want to get rid of the double
standards that we're you know subject to
from the left We complain about all the
time the only way to get rid of it is to
make them
is to apply it to them is to force them
is to basically you're getting rid of
the double standard and you're saying
okay you want to apply these standards
to us we're gonna and we don't like them
but we're gonna apply them right back on
you
it's the only way
um man bot 3000 says I was put in
Special Needs class in seventh grade
that's what they called it in the late
80s all the bad kids some were
intellectually deficient for lack of a
better description most like myself were
troublemakers I actually met three of
those classmates in prison a few short
years later putting all the bad kids in
a room at the end of the hallway isn't a
viable solution thank God he changed uh
lives and today I'm a father of three
happily married and gainfully employed
well congratulations first of all on
being able to get your life together and
this is
the fact that you went through this in
the 80s and this is what they were doing
with kids
um and it was already having that effect
I mean think about how much worse it is
now
because
the discipline the discipline problems
have not gotten any better in the last
30 years they've only gotten worse
and um
they were already just sort of like
taking the back and like I said we said
talked about last week I can remember
this when I was in high school if you
were a troublemaker they just took you
and threw you into a room with other
kids
that are just like you
and that's not gonna that's not gonna
help much but at least back when I was
in in school like you could still punish
kids a little bit
now you can't punish them at all
um
the
natundi says getting divorced because
you don't feel the Sparkles is like
concluding you can't work your job
because you're tired in the morning and
don't want to go and then just quitting
well yeah that is very similar sort of
mentality but that's exactly the
mentality that lots of people have about
their jobs this is this is what they
call you know quiet quitting
people that say it's really yeah it's a
similar kind of thing
so yeah the the country star who said
she had to divorce her husband because I
just didn't feel I didn't feel the the
glitter anymore there was no Glitter and
so she divorced and a lot of people in
their jobs I'd say I don't feel the
glitter anymore in this job
but the difference is they actually
don't quit they're going to keep doing
the job but not trying and expecting to
make the paycheck
Lisa done listening to Matt lost all
credibility on Backstage when he said
Wonderful Christmas Time is the worst
Christmas song ever
everyone knows it's Felice Navidad
sorry that's not even close it's not in
the ballpark Felice Navidad is
I'll tell you right now
if you want a contrary and take Felice
Navidad is a delightful song it's catchy
you know it's catchy it's
catchy it's I mean you can at least call
it catchy you have to agree with me on
that I'm not saying it's my favorite I'm
just saying it doesn't hold a candle to
the putrid pile of audible mush that is
called Wonderful Christmas Time
the song that Paul McCartney wrote in 19
seconds with crayon on the back of a CVS
receipt and That Was Then piped into
every retail store in the country on
repeat from November 1st to the end of
December even though nobody wants to
hear it nobody likes the song nobody
understands why we have to hear it but
it just we just do it's it's a this song
is a god-awful
Nightmare and uh there is there are some
bad Christmas songs out there but
you know but last people always say last
Christmas Felice Navidad those are I
would listen to those
I would listen to last Christmas 10
times in a row before I listen to
Wonderful Christmas Time ones
it's hard to believe it but the holidays
are already here Christmas is upon us
Kwanzaa follows close behind now I know
a lot of you are already daily wire Plus
members and get to enjoy the great
content that we have released this year
like Tara on the Prairie the greatest
lie ever sold and last but certainly not
least my very own documentary what is a
woman for those of you who haven't been
able to enjoy it because you're not a
member now is the time to take advantage
of our 30 holiday sale this applies uh
to gift memberships so as well as as a
regular membership so don't miss this
opportunity to get everyone on your list
an annual gift membership from daily
wire plus with code holiday at checkout
since joining daily wire plus Jordan
Peterson has been on fire with a ton of
content one in particular is a standout
called logos and literacy in which
Jordan went to Washington DC and filmed
a fantastic documentary on the Museum of
the Bible in it Jordan meets with
historians theologians and philosophers
to discuss the history of the Bible and
its influence on the world uh it's
beautiful it's engaging you got to see a
Jordan even send us a note to say how
happy it was with the way it turned out
he actually watched it twice so it tells
you how good it is remember this content
is only available for daily wire Plus
members so sign up today use code
holiday at checkout to get 30 off your
new annual daily wire plus membership at
dailywire.com
Walsh that's dailywire.com Walsh today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
we are now less than a week away from
Christmas a time of joy and celebration
of family togetherness unless you're a
left-wing hypochondriac in which case
it's a horrifying Festival of sickness
and death yes as we get into the
holidays the media has ramped up its
masking push trying to reignite those
germaphobe Sparks recapture the magic of
holiday season's past and many recent
published pieces most media Outlets have
agreed it's time to it's time to once a
day once again Dawn our gay apparel and
by that I mean a mask as CNBC reports
CDC director Rochelle walenski and a
sick call reporter said wearing a mask
is one of the several everyday
precautions that people can take to
reduce their chances of catching or
spreading a respiratory virus during the
holiday season
quote we also encourage you to wear a
high quality well-fitting mask to
prevent the spread of respiratory
illness she said adding that people are
living in areas with high levels of
covert transmission should especially
consider masking the CDC director said
the agency is considering expanding its
system of coveted Community levels to
take into account other respiratory
viruses such as the flu the system is
the basis for when CDC advises the
public to wear masks but wolanski
encouraged people to take proactive
action on Friday night there was a MSNBC
medical analyst who made the case and
perhaps even more strident terms here's
what he said
but to your question yeah
it is well past time especially because
pediatric hospitals across the country
are overwhelmed as you said that we just
need to accept what's unpopular and I'll
just say it that that communities across
the country especially with pediatric
hospitals that are overwhelmed which is
most just need to mask up schools need
to take the leadership here Public
Health officials need to accept uh that
we need that and I know that they
privately communicate this all the time
it's just we need to have the courage to
say this publicly even if it's unpopular
that that communities especially with
hospitals children's hospitals that have
little stock in the system need to
protect those hospitals schools need to
to lead by example and mask and that
school officials I'm looking at you
Public Health officials at the local
level it only makes sense it's our only
buttress share in addition to
vaccination and we need to do it
yes Public Health officials must have
the courage the courage to advocate for
muzzling children a policy that all the
credible evidence suggests was
ineffective pointless and caused far
more harm in terms of educational delays
and psychological damage than it
prevented uh there's a word we might use
for the promotion of policies that were
disastrous disastrously stupid the first
time around and destined to be just as
stupid the next time there are many
words in fact and none of them have
anything to do with courage that's for
certain
but some of the media's renewed
panicking over cobit is driven
by the personal experiences of people in
the media for example a woman named
Tanya Lewis who's a science journalist
for Scientific American tweeted her own
harrowing tale over the weekend she
wrote this well it happened after nearly
three years of covering covet and
thinking about it almost constantly it
finally got me and rather than focus on
how I got it I'm going to tell you how I
didn't get it for this long what follows
uh from from this point is a truly
terrifying glance into the mind of a a
sick woman and I don't mean sick with
covet her sickness is not in the lungs
but in the mind
she continues from the moment we had
evidence that covet might be airborne I
wore a mask not just any mask an n95 or
a well-fitted kn95 at first these were
really hard to come by but now it's
quite easy to find them I don't just
wear it some of the time I wore it
anytime I was indoors in public or even
Outdoors if I was in the crowd I wore
one in the hallways of my apartment
building even if there was no one else
around because aerosols can linger in
the air for a while for the first year
or two I avoided spending time indoors
in public as much as possible with the
exception of grocery stores or doctor's
offices I've wooded the Subways for a
while although studies suggest trains
weren't the biggest vectors for the
spread
she's not done she goes on I did get on
planes a few times to visit a sick
parent need my help but
from the moment I left my apartment to
the moment I arrived I didn't take off
my mask I opened windows and taxis I
didn't eat or drink on the flights
except to sip water while holding my
breath as soon as vaccines became
available I got mine I've gotten every
booster I could since then including the
new bivalent booster that targets uh
omnicorn because we know the coronavirus
is Airborne I only ate at restaurants
with outdoor seating I bought portable
air purifiers and a CO2 monitor to
measure ventilation levels at home I
opened Windows if I was going to visit
an elderly slash immunocompromised
family member I took lots of tests PCR
tests before traveling rapid tests for
several days after arriving I avoided
possible exposures for a week or more
before traveling
so finally we get to the story of how
she still managed to contract the virus
after all this which she blames on the
holiday party she worked that she worked
up the courage to attend uh this year
she wore her n95 to the holiday party
she bathed herself at hand sanitizer she
brought 10 booster shots with her
injected one every 15 minutes she
refused to shake hands with anyone or
speak to them or stand within 50 yards
of anyone I'm only making some of this
up the point is that she emerged
only ever so slightly from her
hypochondriac cocoon after three years
and she still got the virus
what lesson does she learn from this
what lesson does this professional
science writer want us to learn
well of course exactly the opposite of
the actual lesson
indeed she summarizes her experiences at
the end
with with this mind-boggling statement
she says this
quote getting sick doesn't have to be
inevitable
what no Tanya no you you've missed your
own Point your experience proves that
getting sick is inevitable you
structured your entire life around
avoiding the virus for three years and
yet you still got it
I on the other hand have done absolutely
nothing to avoid getting it in fact I've
done the opposite I've spent my time
working in a busy office traveling the
country shaking hands with hundreds of
people at a time
you've done everything not to get sick I
have seemingly done everything to get
sick and we both have had covid the same
number of times since China invented it
once okay you have sacrificed your
normal human existence in favor of a
self-imposed paranoia-fueled self-exile
and in the end you're in exactly the
same spot that all of us out here
breathing fresh air and participating in
society are in
you get sick sometimes
most of the time you don't
until eventually you die
that's the story for almost everyone on
Earth mask or no mask socially distanced
or not socially distanced we are all in
the same boat we all we all must
navigate the world in frail mortal you
know uh bodies subject to all manner of
risks and potential tragedies
you either come to terms with this and
live your life or you hide in fear from
it trembling in Terror and yet still
find yourself subject to the same
inevitabilities that all the rest of us
are
to quote Shawshank Redemption either get
busy living or get busy dying what you
can't choose much to your Chagrin I
realize is a state of suspended
animation where you're neither living
nor dying as you wait for humans to
achieve immortality before re-emerging
into society that is not an option on
the table
in the end what we really learned from
covid or our response to it at any rate
is that some people in our country had
never before the winter of 2020
actually confronted their own mortality
they had never stopped to think about
the fact that Death is certain
that they came into this world and will
have to leave it sooner than they would
like that their own lives are all are
but small blips on the radar screen in
comparison to the lifespan of human
civilization or of the Earth itself
that when considered on that time scale
their lives may as well be five seconds
long
somehow there were many people who had
never really thought about any of this
which came as a shock to those of us
like myself who think about it all the
time
and in a way that may seem ironic to
some people it is those of us who think
about death
uh who are the least liable to panic
over it
because we know that it's coming this
isn't news to us
we know that the world is filled to the
brim with deadly things covet being not
even close to the top of that list
nowhere near it in fact
but those who successfully distracted
themselves from reflecting on their own
mortality who managed to sublimate those
thoughts numb themselves psychologically
and spiritually were jolted quite
Suddenly by the existence of this
relatively mild virus
to them it came out of nowhere like a
vault of lightning
and the constant reminders of death the
one thing they tried to desperately
avoid thinking about
broke them mentally
they were treated into their cocoons
like paranoid little caterpillars and
pledged to never come out until all the
scary stuff is gone and yet it hasn't
gone away and never will
and still they cannot bring themselves
to Simply accept the terrible truth that
life is short
no matter what and we will all die
and it will probably hurt and we will
not like it
but there is no way to stop it
death lurks around the corner for all of
us
no matter which direction we choose to
walk
any step might be our last
so Merry Christmas
and Tanya uh you're canceled
we'll leave it there for today uh moving
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign